make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay before we jump into
this video i do want to pitch a question
to you guys
if myself and mariah my fiance if we
made like a vlogging channel
would you guys watch it like would you
guys want to watch it i'm just kind of
curious
i'm we're just kind of spitballing ideas
i just wanted to pick your all's brains
and see how receptive you would be to
that but let me know down in the comment
section would you guys watch that
vlogging channel where it's just me and
mariah goofing off doing like going
buying comic books or you know eating
food in different places right like
testing food at different restaurants
and so on we don't really know what form
it'll take but let me know right i'm
just kind of curious what you guys think
so we are picking up with the juggernaut
one shot and here's the thing i've been
looking forward to this for a long time
right this is the juggernaut's you know
own personal series now this is
technically the third volume that the
juggernauts had in terms of his own solo
series so don't really expect this to be
like a super long lived series right
we're probably not going to see this
reach anything like 50 or 60 issues if
i'm a betting man i'd say at most it'll
get to about 12 to 15
and then marvel will call it a day it
could go longer and i hope that it does
but for the most part juggernaut's never
really been a character who's been able
to hold his series for a long time but
hopefully we can change that rob core
hopefully you guys buy enough of these
comics that we kind of keep it going for
a good long time but
this story is written by fabian necessa
and this guy is og double og
phobia in the season here's here's the
thing i know rob lightfeld fans are
gonna be pissed with me
don't care i feel like fabian necessa
was the brains behind the operation
this guy was the one who just basically
made it all work in the 1990s i don't
care what anybody says they can come to
me and they can pitch me some story
about how rob liefeld was the one who
made deadpool and all that kind of stuff
maybe he did but the only reason why
deadpool's comics and the really even
deadpool is a character and the only
reason why the x-force comics were
awesome in the 1990s was because of
fabian necessa right so the idea here
is is this picks up but not really it
picks up during like what's going on
with the x-men right now
but there is a bit of an explanation
that we need to offer but we'll offer
that here in a minute right what this
does is it basically picks up
basically a manhattan and you end up
having kane marco who's really just
working for damage control and that's
kind of the crazy thing here but that's
kind of
the nut situation about this is remember
damage control those are the ones that
basically deal in the aftermath of like
buildings being cr i'm sorry uh
superhero battles different things like
that and so in the aftermath of like the
war of realms different things like that
when you basically had like the battle
of new york and so on and so forth which
is actually one of the things you're
looking for
right residual traces from the nine
realms basically indicating that like
there's some magic here that can either
be used by the government or
uh there's nothing to really concern
themselves with whenever you have
massive calamities that take place
and it leads to the destruction of
property in the united states and
sometimes even across the world damage
control are the ones who respond to it
now how they respond to it varies from
story's story the result to this is that
kane marco isn't necessarily a bad guy
here and that's what's so awesome about
this that's that's why i'm so glad
fabian is writing this
at this point in time because as opposed
to getting kane marco where he's just
you know just lumbering along and
destroying things because blard kane
marco charles xavier is bad
instead of getting something like that
we actually get like some pretty cool
nuance to this character that what he's
doing right now is he's basically just
demolishing buildings for damage control
and he's the best person suited for it
but the other issue that they're running
into is they're basically running into
squatters right which is to say homeless
individuals specifically homeless
teenagers who are just taking up
residence inside of these various
properties right these various homes
derelict buildings different things like
that
now the funny thing about this is that
there is an actual legal doctrine called
squatters rights and you guys have
probably heard of that before
but basically what it means is say for
example that like i owned
owned a house somewhere and say for
example that i left that house vacant
for
like a year and uh like a vagrant a
homeless person were to just show up
there
and manage to find their way into the
house and then take up residence in it i
can't just like
go in there and grab all their stuff and
throw it on the curb like they actually
have squatters rights meaning i have to
treat them like a tenant that hasn't
paid rent and go through the entire
eviction process now different states
have different laws some states i don't
think recognize squatters right so like
if a squatter just walks into a property
and takes up residence you can just go
in there guns blazing and chase them out
it depends i think on what state you're
talking about i don't really know the
state to state law so i'm not going to
quote any in specific
but it's one of the things that they're
having to deal with here like basically
young kids now the issue is on the
surface juggernaut's like okay i'll go
take care of them and then suddenly the
juggernaut is stopped dead in this track
so not really stopped in his tracks but
enough to where he can't really seem to
be able to move in a forward direction
now this is a big deal and this is one
of these instances when fabian caesar
does something
that's absolutely genius because we've
only ever really seen a couple of
instances that i know of off the top of
my head or a person's been able to stop
the juggernaut right it's the core
nature of his powers once the juggernaut
starts moving
virtually nothing can stop him now we
are taking we are we are treating this
with a little bit of common sense right
so like things like cosmic entities can
obviously stop the juggernaut a person
who can warp reality can stop the
juggernaut a person who can levitate him
using you know telekinesis can stop the
juggernaut like a little bit of common
sense there those kind of things can do
that but in terms of like sheer force
there really aren't there really isn't
anything out there the only real
instance that i'm aware of of that
happening i think was
maybe with onslaught although i don't
remember off top my head he was able to
punch jogger on a juggernaut across the
country so you know that kind of speaks
for itself and then the incredible hulk
when he was powered by the
uh by celestro technology from
apocalypse as well as the hero's reborn
universe right so like that's when he
was able to basically stop the
juggernaut deadness tracks
but the juggernauts basically caught
unawares here right the squadrons are
just like stay away from here or you're
going to get worse but the juggernaut's
totally caught by surprise because one
of the questions of the
of the guys from damage control is did
one of the teenagers have like a kinetic
they have like kinetic force powers like
were they able to basically manipulate
kinetic energy and that's one of the
questions that juggernaut has is like
whoever this kid
is the juggernaut wants to know who they
are right he wants to get his hands on
him but the cool thing about this is we
end up basically jumping back to a few
months ago now this is where the
explanation kind of comes into play a
little bit in terms of where the
juggernaut has been and the reason why
is we haven't really seen kane marco
since the end of matt rosenberg's run on
x-men going into the house of x stories
by jonathan hickman and what we ended up
getting there was
uh was a story arc called we are like we
we are alive or we are minnie or
something along those lines i don't
remember i know we've we've always been
here i think it's what is what it was
called but basically it was the final
story arc and it ended up seeing a
couple things happen with kane marco the
first
was that a general by the name of at
least a guy by the name of general
callahan
ended up basically suppressing the
mutant gene of of iliana rasputin which
released her darker half also known as
dark child which is basically
all the powers of iliana rasputin with
none of like her morality
basically but what ended up happening is
dark child basically ripped the crystal
out of uh out of kane marcos stripped
him of his powers and then threw him in
limbo right threw him in into the limbo
dimension and he had just kind of
resided there right he just sort of
showed up there and he's just a small
frail guy right i mean the reason why
he's so colossal in size
is because of all the powers that the
gem amps or the gem offers him which is
all of his powers as well as
an intimidating size and so one of the
things that he ends up doing is
basically kind of string is
stringing his armor together as best he
can which is astronomically heavy and
then just dragging it along the ground
right until he gets to a point whereby
he can basically escape limbo and so
from there
we end up you know picking up kind of in
the modern day you know in this moment
right now with juggernaut basically
walking through this place where all
these squatters are taking up residence
and again
it's not so much what juggernaut does
here that's so interesting is what he
doesn't do under normal circumstances if
this was like 20 years ago kane marco
would have just rampaged through these
buildings and who cares if the kids died
or not right this job is to demolish the
buildings and the buildings have been
demolished if they didn't want to die
they wouldn't stay there that became
marco's line of logic
[Laughter]
he's not wrong but it's still kind of a
dick thing to do right but at this point
he's taking a more gentler hand
and the reason why really seems to be
fabian to caesa pushing towards the idea
that with kane marco being locked in
limbo the way he was and being without
his powers he basically had to come to
terms with who he was and what he was
about what's the role of juggernaut in
the bigger picture is he really just
this great big lumbering beast who's not
too smart just kind of rampaging
throughout the world tearing stuff
up and getting beat by the x-men every
once in a while or is there something
more to his character that he hasn't
quite figured out yet and so he
basically shows up here and says look
guys i'm not here to tear the building
down but i i have demolished enough
buildings to know this thing's barely
hanging on but i'm here to help you guys
out like i'm here you know because one
of you guys is basically a mutant right
now at that
point juggernaut is basically seized by
these powers like he's
he's essentially seized by these powers
and just kind of sent crashing down and
that's when he starts to realize that
this person is not really using a force
field right they're not using
telekinesis or anything like that that
it really is the manipulation of kinetic
energy more so than that
this person is able to control kinetic
energy they can slow things down they
can speed things up and it's basically
this girl who calls herself d cell who
says she's not a mutant now i know i
titled this video a new omega level
mutant but i'm reserving judgment on
this and the reason why is because for
anybody who's been reading fabian in a
season for any real measure of time he
is a guy who isn't necessarily full of
tricks but he is a guy who does like to
pull a red herring right he is a guy who
likes to kind of send you looking in one
direction only to kind of pull the rug
out from under you right so while this
girl d
cell kind of claims she's not a mutant
i'm reserving judgment and i'm going to
assume that she is but i kind of i kind
of feel like she is but using her powers
what she's able to do
is basically slow down the momentum of
juggernaut and that's
it's a genius idea the issue with this
is that because of the power that
juggernaut possesses
because of how durable how strong he is
and the fact that he's basically backed
by what is more or less
a godly cosmic being and the fact that
like the the toll is so extreme
it basically ends up kind of knocking
out decel now of course when that
happens juggernaut falls there's this
great big huge kind of collapse you know
that that goes on and he's like guys
drop your phones for a second and like
help me get this girl out right help me
clear out this rubble and from there
she's taken to bellevue trauma center
and kay marco actually stays with her
and this is kind of the nurturing hand
of kane marco it's very uncharacteristic
and under normal circumstances we as
comic book fans don't necessarily like
it when our when when the characters
that we read about are written out of
character which is really kind of a
weird explanation to have
because at the end of the day it's just
whatever version of the character that
we like more the idea here is that he
basically kind of talks to her and says
hey look like you know you're obviously
a mutant that has
has like these interesting powers i can
help you get to krakowa
right i can help you get to where the
mutants live now here's a couple things
one big thing that i kind of want to
address here right one one big thing
that i want to talk about here
one of the big reasons why kane marco is
a guy who's kind of turning over a new
leaf is not just because of what's
happening in this story that's kind of
that really kind of seems to be the end
result of what he's been through but
what ended up happening during the
events of
matt rosenberg's x-men run is he had
actually approached cyclops
juggernaut has for some time been
working to kind of turn over a new leaf
but one of the things she says you know
one of the things that desal says is
like i'm not a mutant and kate marco
kind of makes this funny comment he's
like you know with the name diesel it
does make you sound like a battery right
and she's like well you know juggernaut
makes you sound like
i don't know she can't think of anything
she's like i don't know it's a cool name
and it is
it's a very cool name here's my question
if you could give yourself a superhero
name what would it be
right like if you could name yourself
something because i know you guys have
don't tell me that you haven't i'm not
going to tell you mine
mine's kind of embarrassing but you guys
have to tell me yours
this is a one-way street of friendship
robcor so with that being the case we
end up having this scenario where where
we kind of jump back to limbo and we
actually end up picking up in a place
called the crossroads now fabian esquida
kind of plays this fast and loose and
i'm not
overly familiar with limbo but i am
familiar enough to know that this
basically looks like the nexus right is
essentially what this looks like and the
reason why is because of course you have
a tree and you have all these hands
pointing in different directions and the
question of
juggernaut is like where do i go to get
out of here but the reality is that in
order to escape limbo you basically have
to sacrifice a portion of yourself which
is to say you have to sacrifice
something
from before in order to move forward
right it's just kind of one of the many
laws of limbo that exist out there and
when he kind of tells this story to
detail her question is
if you left your armor there how do you
still have it he's like it's a different
armor it's a longer story right so it
looks like we're actually going to get
that explanation in terms of kane
marco's new suit and what his new suit's
capable of if it's capable of anything
different from his old suit the other
part of this is that uh diesel's friends
had actually recorded the altercation
between herself and juggernaut on what's
called her rocks tube channel so
basically roxanne oil
uh has like a social media platform
which is obviously youtube because
youtube
seems to have his hands some pretty cd
things at the very least you know
they've got their own fair share of
problems that they deal with and the
idea is that the videos of course got
like a million views right which is a
lot of views that's
bunches of views right that's that's a
lot of views i remember there was a time
on youtube once upon a time
when people believed that you would get
like that as a creator you'd make like a
dollar per view and it's like if you got
a million views you got like a million
dollars and it's like man i wish that
would be
nuts i'd be like pewdiepie i'd make
videos for a year and quit like it'd be
it would be insane but the idea here is
is that kate marcos like okay look when
he asks her about her powers
she explains it in this really
interesting way and this really goes
into why it is and i'm calling her what
is more or less a new omega level mutant
that what she's able to do is control
the speed of objects
and so there's an instance where she
talks about how this youtube channel
that she has with her friends that they
basically pull pranks
and that one of the things that they did
for example was they basically made an
elevator take an hour to get to the
floor
or during the women's world cup parade
that she made the confetti take five
hours to fall just by manipulating its
speed now on the surface this is throw
away but if you extrapolate this out
and you apply the principle of an omega
level mutant to this and you say that
it's a person with no upper limit this
is a girl that could slow down the
earth's rotation this is a girl that
could slow down the movement of
everybody throughout the world she's a
person that could slow down how fast
plant
or how how fast plant life grows across
the world this is a girl that could slow
down could speed it up right she
could age you up super fast right she
could if she can control the speed of
objects then with enough control she can
control the speed of matter and if she
can control the speed of matter
then she becomes a person who can
basically speed up and slow down matter
at any rate she chooses and as we know
like
heat is the result of friction which is
matter moving rapid moving at a rapid
pace against something else
and being able to do that is basically
the ability to create explosions there's
no real limit to the kind of things this
girl could do but she's certainly a
planetary threat i mean imagine if like
tomorrow
you went to bed it was monday and then
you woke up and it was friday right just
like time fat time passed that fast
right the ability to just kind of
speed things up assuming that you could
alter matter which is space and time on
that level
even on a smaller level the sun sets and
rises in the span of like three hours
like
just that kind of stuff it's cool it's
amazing not to mention like the the
impact it would have on earth's life of
right on
like the entire existence of humanity
and all sentient beings or nonsensient
beings on earth if just like the speed
of everything was sped up or slowed down
so again there's
there's a case to make here that this
girl is a is a beyond
like is an omega level character right
like she has omega level powers
it just depends on what level uh fabian
decision wants to push them to but the
other thing about this is of course she
doesn't reveal her real name right so
there's basically building a little bit
of mystery and the fact that her and
kane marco will probably have some
adventures together different things
like that but
it's the other thing where she basically
says hey like you should check this out
right like the idea is that if kane
marco is working for damage control and
the idea is to control damage then she
in turn basically presents him with what
one of her subscribers told her which is
basically just the immortal hulk going
on a rampage
and so it's kind of like you have to
stop this right like i mean if your
whole job is to get sick or tail damage
and you want to be a good guy then it's
time for you to start being a good guy
and step up to the immortal hulk and so
what we're gonna end up getting
is basically the new juggernaut against
the immortal hulk and i am excited for
that
[Laughter]
i am so excited for that but that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
corps if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you